To determine whether there are genetic factors
underlying bipolar disorder, monozygotic and dizygotic studies have
actually been employed. Now in these studies
it was found monozygotic twins show a concordance
of 62% for bipolar disorder. And that
dizygotic twins show a concordance rate of 8%.
This was true for twins reared together and twins reared apart. So based on just
this information alone I want you to tell
me which of the following is most likely to
be true. Bipolar disorder is explained completely by genetic
factors where there's a strong genetic component that's influenced
by the environment or there's a weak genetic component
that's mainly influenced by the environment. Or the bipolar
disorder can be explained completely by environmental factors. Go
ahead and pick which answer you think is best.